AS WE GO TO
OUR NEXT GAME, "FASHION WEAK."
LAST WEEK, TEMPORARILY, THE
INTERNET TRADED
PICTURES OF CATS AND FEDORAS FOR
PICTURES OF CATWALKS AND
THOUSAND-DOLLAR FEDORAS AS PART
OF NEW YORK FASHION WEEK.
AS EXPECTED, THE ANNUAL
GATHERING OF TOP DESIGNERS AND
HUMAN STICK BUGS INCLUDED
OUTFITS THAT EVEN BJORK WOULD
FIND MILDLY UPSETTING.
SO, COMEDIANS, WE'VE COLLECTED
SOME OF THE MOST MYSTIFYING
FASHION WEEK LOOKS, AND I'D LIKE
YOU TO TELL ME WHAT THESE
OUTFITS ARE CALLED.
I'M STARTING THE CLOCK NOW.
FIRST ONE.
WHAT IS THAT?
JUSTIN?
>> SNAKE WITH TITS.
>> Chris: FINALLY, POINTS.
DOUG BENSON.
CARLY FIORINA GOES TO BURNING
MAN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
>> MAD MAX: FURIOUS BONER.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
RON.
>> SPONGEBOB SQUARETITS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
DOUG.
BATH MAT KNEEPAD.
>> CHRIS: POINTS
>> I CALL THEM LIKE I SEE THEM,
CHRIS.
>> Chris: YOU SURE DID.